[Musique]
merci coach merci d'être là et c'est
vrai que Dieu sait qu'on a besoin de vos
conseils aujourd'hui je crois que
ce qu'il y a pour moi un style
vestimentaire particulier pour être
charismatique alors très bonne question
Cyril
il y a beaucoup d'idées reçues sur le
style et le charisme beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'il y a des tenues
vestimentaires charismatiques c'est faux
d'ailleurs je vais même vous expliquer
quelque chose
on peut savoir si quelqu'un est
charismatique si il peut tout porter
Cyril on voit que vous partez dans
plusieurs registres ça peut aller du
jogging au costard tout vous va je vais
même appuyer mon exemple
[Applaudissements]
j'ai appuyé mon exemple par une
démonstration toute simple si vous vous
habillez tout en cuir si oui on va tout
de suite se projeter et vous imaginez
sur une Harley Davidson par exemple
route 66 avec quelques Barbies autour de
vous born to be wild Gilles Verdez
tout en cuir on va l'imaginer suspendu à
des cordes une boule dans la bouche
Gilles Verdez n'est pas charismatique
fin du tuto
la démonstration est toute simple alors
que pensez-vous par exemple du style de
ma chérie ma préférée ma chouchoute
Daniel alors vous savez que je suis
quelqu'un de franc oui ah merde
c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai mes clients
me font confiance on ne passe pas par
quatre chemins
Daniel je dois le dire et vous le savez
tous on va pas se mentir à partir d'un
certain âge une femme n'est plus
charismatique
on est plus désirable alors je dirais
quand même que Daniel est une forme
d'exception malgré tout malgré tout il y
a quelque chose d'authentique chez vous
si je pouvais me permettre de faire une
métaphore je dirais que vous êtes un
petit peu comme une belle limousine
voilà je parle pas de la voiture je
parle de la vache
[Rires]
laissez-moi aller au bout de ma
démonstration ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose
d'authentique de rural chez vous je
pense qu'en campagne vous pourriez avoir
un impact charismatique sur sur des
champs et je vous imagine je sais que
vous êtes célibataire alors pas pour
longtemps je suis sur le positionné bien
bien positionné je pense que vous
pourriez rencontrer l'amour à la
campagne et comme ça alors elle est elle
adore un agriculteur de l'amour et dans
le pré donc
vos jours aux côtés d'un d'un paysan
voilà jusqu'à jusqu'à l'abattoir
pour rester dans la métaphore la
métaphore attention c'est pas de la
méchanceté c'est de la poésie j'essaye
de
la poésie
alors Stéphane que pensez-vous du style
de Géraldine maillet
bon
j'avais demandé à ce qu'on me pose pas
la question alors
[Rires]
Géraldine le problème c'est que je ne
peux pas travailler avec vous parce que
ce ne serait pas le professionnel qui
parle mais l'homme
un petit peu la manière d'un psychologue
avec son patient il risquerait d'y avoir
des transferts des choses on pourrait
pas travailler ensemble voilà il y a
une espèce d'attirance mutuelle
[Rires]
alors je sais que vous êtes vous êtes en
couple absolument oui que Daniel Riolo
on embrasse on l'embrasse bien sûr je
pense que vous méritez d'être avec un
homme de taille normale
[Rires]
le mec regarde d'en haut pas un homme
qui vous regarde d'en bas ce sont les
enfants qui regardent les femmes d'en
bas
dans un lit en tout cas
c'est vrai que là en matière de là c'est
le fin du fin alors c'est de la suédine
c'est 500 balles la peur
[Applaudissements]
alors ce que vous avez une astuce pour
rendre charismatique
ah ça c'est intéressant comme question
ce n'est pas de la magie c'est quoi le
charisme c'est aussi un parcours
d'accord une vie je vais prendre sur un
exemple monsieur Bigard monsieur Bigard
arrive dans un restaurant ouais qui
arrive dans un restaurant les gars 40
ans de carrière d'accord
pardon c'est qui non c'est rien c'est
les impôts le charisme c'est un peu tous
là c'est le charisme
immobilière
il bosse
m'aiment bien que les femmes s'habillent
en cuir parce que ça leur rappelle
l'odeur d'une bagnole neuve
[Rires]
Jean-Marie arrive dans un restaurant les
gens se retournent c'est 40 ans de
carrière d'où vient Jean-Marie son
background il vient de remplir le stade
de France d'accord Guillaume Genton
arrive dans un restaurant d'où vient
Guillaume Genton il vient de chez
chantalou coiffure il a raté sa
coloration
c'est dur mais c'est comme ça c'est un
pas que vous avez mais vous avez encore
du temps pour vous améliorer vos
background
notre astuce ou bien on passe à un autre
sujet j'aurais bien aimé parler de
justement
[Rires]
Béatrice
[Applaudissements]
quand vous entrez dans un restaurant
Béatrice c'est une actrice donc là il y
a quelque chose qui se passe c'est un
impact sur les gens alors c'est une
actrice furtive vous avez des rôles
c'est normal c'est une actrice tout de
même
il y a les acteurs qui sont les têtes
d'affiches de film vous faites partie
des acteurs qui passent une tête dans un
film
c'est déjà pas mal c'est exactement j'ai
vu Batman alors je n'ai pas vu votre
votre moment parce que j'ai cligné des
US à ce moment-là
vous avez malgré tout eu un impact sur
mon inconscient et c'est charismatique
d'une certaine manière vous susciter la
curiosité quand vous arrivez dans un
restaurant les gens se tient je l'ai
déjà vu quelque part ou je ne sais pas
mais je l'ai vu donc vous attirez le
regard de l'autre il y a les actrices
sublimes les actrices subliminales
vous êtes une sublime actrice
subliminale
c'est beau moi sublime que Géraldine
voilà à mon tour de faire passer un
message
faut faire confiance au destin de votre
côté ouais si vous voulez mais pas du
mien quoi alors je peux rien vous
promettre pour le moment parce que j'ai
un agenda qui est assez
ok on trouvera quelques choses
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise d'autre je pense que j'ai déjà j'ai
déjà un petit peu tout dit pour ce soir
Raymond on peut imaginer Raymond rentrer
dans un restaurant aussi c'est
intéressant alors le background c'est
pareil quand Raymond on rentre dans un
restaurant
au pire on ne le voit pas et au mieux on
le prend pour le serveur voilà
c'est comme ça que c'est la vérité je
suis là pour dire la vérité c'est aussi
ça le charisme d'accord le style le
background d'accord donc là ici ça ne
marche pas pour tout le monde parce que
Géraldine et Jean-Marie le bacon et
Géraldine
je voulais dire la dernière fois il y a
ce côté beaucoup trop accessible alors
là c'est fait moi boulangère cette
semaine je crois
encore une fois il y a un côté
secrétaire médical
[Musique]
on a coupé les ponts
je pense que c'est quelqu'un alors fait
partie de ces clients qu'on ne peut pas
coacher c'est ça voilà c'est ça on peut
pas vous coacher
[Applaudissements]
il veut me faire payer mon coaching de
la dernière fois je dirais simplement
commencer par payer vos dettes monsieur
[Applaudissements]